let's do seeking validation right so
this is another red flag on the list so
if you're dating a woman and she's using
social media to seek validation and
attention outside of the relationship
then that's the problem right
um
Instagram for example uh Twitter mostly
Instagram because Instagram's more
photography based but if she's posting
sexy selfies provocative photographs
um you're on vacation with her or you're
doing something and she's taking a
picture of the food but you're not in
the picture or she wants a picture with
the sunset and you're not in the picture
it's just her that's the woman that's
seeking validation she's looking for
like she's fishing for life she's
fishing for comments and make no mistake
uh guys are going to be dming her hey
hey beautiful what are you doing this
that and the other thing most of it she
just ignores but the fact that she's
doing that is a reality that you have to
contend with today because she's looking
for attention and marketing herself
online so if you want to see if a woman
really loves you if she's really looking
at you the best that you know she can
possibly get tell her to shut down her
Instagram see if she does that for you
because a woman that loves you that sees
you as her best option will do it if she
has genuine burning desire for you and
would fear losing you you know to
another woman she'll shut down on our
Instagram at the very least if you're
dating a woman her social media should
not be posting provocative pictures
especially if she says hey Rich I dig
your Vibe where do we stand I want to
claim you I don't want to share you with
anybody else especially then by the way
women women should have that talk with
you it's not you opening the word We
Stand talk women open that talk up okay
you never start that so if she's done
that and she's posting those pictures
that's when you go well I like you too
but I don't take women seriously that
post-provocative pictures online so what
are we going to do about that
I'll just close down my account
perfect no problem oh why are you trying
to control me yeah that happened you
know yeah that's when you're like well
like I said I don't take women seriously
that post-provocative pictures online so
if you want to get with me that's gonna
have to stop right
now I I had did this one and they did
that and I was with them and they would
have a sexy shirt on whatever and really
you know okay but if we're gonna date
and again if I'm going to meet you rich
okay I don't want her walking at me you
and her are gonna go to dinner I'm
dressed nice you're dressed nice I am
not taking her with me with her cleavage
hanging out and everything else because
to me it's trashy but you but you say
something to them and they say oh you're
jealous or you're controlling or you're
you're too old or you know that's the
response you get and if I have better
options you just move on yeah there'd be
a lot of single guys I'll tell you what
you know the the uh guys guys value
increases as we get older we only get
better as we get older like I meant like
men peak in their late 30s early 40s I'm
older than that so I'll be honest right
like I'm on the decline you know at this
stage but but men do get better as they
age especially if they've done work on
in their life they've chased sex since
they've made money women Peak at 22-23
because women and men are different men
are success objects and women are Beauty
objects so women Peak around 21 22 23.
that's when if you survey
cross-culturally and they've done this
they've asked men around the world they
show them pictures of women of all ages
from the 20s all the way up to like 70
or something like that universally
cross-culture across religion they all
universally select about 21 22 years old
and women hate that when you say that
that's misogynistic why are you just
instilling us down to objects
it's always been that way for thousands
of years women have always been Beauty
objects to men and men have always been
success objects to women
that's the way it is and I know you've
seen it you know you go online and I
would go online I'm having a guest in
whoever and I would go online and just
you know look to see who they are what
they're about to have a good
conversation with
and then I would see their wife and I
would see what they're wearing and hey
if they're okay with that that's fine
but to me
sometimes I would almost fall over
because back in my day back in my Heyday
when I wasn't a committed guy I mean I
would attack that right away be just
based on the fact of what you're wearing
and how you're presenting yourself so to
me it's like marketing yourself like
buddy you might want to say something to
her you know well it makes her feel good
this that the other my friend she's at
like this is what I say and I you know
excuse my language if you don't like it
but she's saying come [__] me I mean you
know when you're when you're in that
little thing and the dress is up and
you're married with kids and you're
doing the the what do they call that the
boomerang it's like come [__] me I'm
like dude that's like even friends like
try to be nice you know and then you
know of course I get they don't like me
and I'm like dude your your wife is on
Instagram basically shimad's what would
you know be on a hooker site yeah
precisely exactly 100 right I mean you
she she's a representation of you I
wouldn't want to take my gal out if if
if she had a only fans if she had an
Instagram where she's constantly showing
her her body off if I had to take her
out to a dinner and she's wearing a nice
evening gown maybe like cut down the
back when she's got tattoos on her back
you don't want that as a guy and women
don't seem to understand that it doesn't
seem to sink in that men Value Beauty
Purity you know conservative type of
like women that are that are only there
for like you want a freak in the bedroom
you don't want them in the streets right
right yeah you want the free you do not
want to take that to you know we had a
meeting with uh Magic Johnson birthday
party you know you don't regardless of
what he's doing he's already on his 10
gazillion million dollar Jet right so it
doesn't matter what he's doing right
we're coming in as a little guy I don't
want to go in there with some chick half
naked I want a classy looking girl you
know not with tons of jewelry you know a
nice necklace nice like a proper and for
some reason like you said
if you say proper or classy that means
you're you're old sexist you're old
you're sexist you're jealous you're uh
good call me that yeah yeah that's what
I am then that's what I am yeah yeah
that was that valid you got to read that
that's a really good one and uh give it
give another one of these slides Rob I'm
giving this book
um let's go to hissy Fitz
so
kids kids throw Hissy Fits you got kids
Rob yeah two you know two boys they'll
get mad they'll uh you know they get
down on the ground they'll bang their
fists sort of thing
you know if things don't go their way
fine you know they don't know how to
deal with their emotions but when you're
an adult you can't be throwing Hissy
Fits if you can't control your emotions
as an adult woman and you know you get
mad and you're slamming things you're
throwing things you're slamming doors
car doors front doors you just as a guy
you want a peaceful life you want a
woman that's a compliment to your life
not a woman that's complicating your
life and a woman that throws Hissy Fits
is going to add unnecessary stress to
your life that you really don't need I
don't want to be going out in my world
chasing Excellence making money putting
a dent in reverse and I come back to a
woman an adult female throwing a hissy
fit right
um so she's got to be able to deal with
conflict she's got to be able to resolve
it she's got to be able to have some
control over her emotions iffy fits are
really a big red flag too and Rich you
know they go on and on and on and again
like I said in the past I would have a
big meeting like a really important
meeting or a really important guess
where I had to like I'd read your book
look at all your websites you're not
just a one thing type of guy you know
where you sit down hey Rich how you
doing you know you got all kinds you got
three uh YouTubes you you got a book you
got the podcast you got all kinds of
stuff going on you know and these
history fits they bring up something and
they just keep going on and on and on
and on when correct me if I'm wrong but
I think us men okay what's the problem
okay that's the problem okay how can we
fix it okay it's done period no more to
talk about but they go on and on and on
and on that would fit into the hissy fit
category right yes if it's broad you
know she doesn't like something you say
a boundary that you set she goes out and
breaks another boundary you know she'll
make a derogatory post on social media
that you know is about you know the
hissy fit that she just threw because
she doesn't like something that you did
it's you know it's just childish
behavior and like I said you know you
want a woman that's a compliment to your
life not a woman that complicates your
life and the best and I'm sure you've
seen this uh you know when you're
talking and people that come to you they
have a hissy fit with you and then they
go tell everybody about the hit they go
to the committee and tell the committee
all about the hissy fit and then they
keep bringing the hissy foot back up
again and again and again with the
committee yeah yeah it's a never-ending
cycle you don't you don't want to deal
with any of that as a guy guys do but
you don't really want to trust me I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out